>>> NIGHT SURVEILLANCE STATE.
CHINA'S POLICE STATE USING CELL
PHONE SIGNALS REPORTED IN THE
VICINITY OF PROTEST STRIKES TO
TRACK, PROTEST, DETAIN ANYONE
WHO WAS THERE.
THE IT COMES AS NEW IMAGES ARE
EMERGING OF UNRUST.
INTENDING TO CUT METAL CHAINS
TRYING TO BREAK TRUE.
YOU SEE THAT AS THEY TRY TO
BREAK FREE.
A MAN IS REFUSING TO GO TO A
QUARANTINE FACILITY.
THE FELLAS IN HAASE MATT SUITS
ARE DRAGGING THEM OUT.
AND IN YET ANOTHER PROVINCE.
>> Reporter: WHY IS IT EVERY
TIME YOU SPEAK A SENTENCE OF
PROOF, THAT MY BERNTS, YEAH?
WHY NOT LET THEM SPEAK THE
TRUTH?
>> CHINESE PRESIDENT XI JINPING
UNLEASHED THE REPORT.
TONIGHT THE GOVERNMENT SAYS IT'S
TAKING SOME SMALL STEPS TOWARDS
EASING SOME RESTRICTIONS BUT IS
THIS JUST LIP SERVICE?
IS THIS GOING TO CAUSE PROBLEMS.
VIVIAN WANG IS SORT OF JUST
STICKING OUT HERE.
ONE DEMONSTRATOR SAID THEY GOT A
PHONE CALL BECAUSE AN OFFICER
TRACKED THEM DOWN.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> WE'RE SEEING A MIX OF SORT OF
HIGH TECH.
ALSO OLD-FASHIONED TACTICS.
WE'VE HEARD POLICE STOPPING
PEOPLE ON THE SIDEWALK.
PT HAVE YOU SEEN ANY?
IT'S A MIXTURE AND WE CAN
FASHION BREAK IT.
TWO AUTHORITIES IN HAZMAT SUITS.
YOU HAVE BEEN COVERING THIS
STORY EXTENSIVELY FROM BEIJING,
RIGHT?
YOU'VE BEEN LIVING THERE WITH
THE LOCKDOWN ITSELF AND NOW THEY
SAY THEY'RE EASING RESTRICTIONS.
ARE THESE NOTABLE RESTRICTIONS.
IS THIS GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO
SATISFY THE PROTESTERS?
>> IT'S HARD TO SAY TO ALL OF
YOUR QUESTIONS.
IN BEIJING YOU NO LONGER NEED A
COVID TEST TO GET ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF POWER
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE AND THERE
WERE WERE NO PEOPLE TO WORRY
ABOUT.
IT'S A VERY DISPARATE GROUP WITH
A LOT OF DEMAND.
>> FOR THE PEOPLE WITH BROADER
DEMANDS ABOUT DEMOCRACY, FREEDOM
OF SPEECH, PROBABLY NOT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING YOUR
REPORTING FROM US.
NOW IN BEIJING.
SHE'S HOST OF "THE PRINCIPLES"
ABOUT CHINA'S LEAD JR. XI
JINPING.
YOU'VE DONE SUCH EXTENSIVE
REPORTING.
HOW DO YOU THINK HE'S BEEN SINCE
CHINA.
>> THE PROTESTS WE SAW OVER THE
WEEKEND WERE ABSOLUTELY
EXTRAORDINARY.
PEOPLE CAN PAY VERY, VERY HIGH
PRICE FOR PROTESTING IN XI JING
PENG'S QUESTION.
YOU'RE FROM CG PING'S
PERSPECTIVE.
IT WAS A HAND FALL OF THINGS.
>> YOU KNOW, THE IMAGES THAT
KEEP COMING OUT THOUGH, THEY
REALLY ARE -- IT IS AMAZING TO
THINK, GOSH, WE'RE LIVING OFF
THE SAME PLANET.
SUE LYNN, YOU ARE FEELING THIS.
THE THIS IS A COMMON SITE.
FIRST STAGE HERE OF 2020 IN
WUHAN.
>> THIS EXERCISE.
THE WHY DO YOU THINK SHE'S DOING
IT.
>> THOSE VIDEOS HONEST.
IT KIND OF HARKENS BACK TO THE
EARLY PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC, I
THINK WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER IN XI JINPING'S
FAMILIAR.
IF YOU ARE A COMMUNIST PARTY
OFFICIAL, IT'S MOST IMPORTANT
YOU SHOW AND UP UNTIL NOW THAT
HAS BEEN ALL ABOUT THE ZERO
COVID POLICY.
YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP HIM IN YOUR FLOWER
R -- QUEENS.
IN WALES AND THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
>> THIS IS SORT OF LIKE THE
VI